hello freak bitches oh I did BET's
comicview thrice three times yeah so I
mean like who was hosting the first one
ever was Lester Barry who was a black
circuit comic but very religious nice
the second time I did it was Arnez J in
Miami and the third time third time was
funny cuz I said by this point I go I'm
not doing comic feel ever again like
that's why just I've written that one
off I'm not doing it it's always an
awkward situation when I go there too
why because I'm the only white guy the
production is white and they put some
weird responsibility on me to be like
the den mother of the comics No so I
think smoke cigarettes and I'd go
outside mama go outside and smell the
signatures okay wait a second Jews
everyone J's going to smoke if you want
to smoke go out now with him and
everyone's gotta be back in here in 15
minutes and and then she gate tried to
give me all of their food tickets so I'd
be responsible for them it was very
bizarre just because you're white yeah I
may I assume so why that said a lot of
the black comments will do things like
I'm gonna go out and smoke and then go
like you know fuck a chick for five
works try to come back 50 minutes before
the show starts like that did happen
well what they want you to do just hang
out all day waiting for the show star oh
they put you there at 9:00 in the
morning until night I went on at
midnight
what yeah because they just don't want
these wrangle everybody say they don't
believe any day yeah I know you know
belief they're gonna stay there they've
done entire shows about how happy they
are like they'll do a show where the
same joke gets repeated by different
comedians well yeah and so what I went
did it Kevin Hart and then a posting the
who I think one of the last ever seasons
but it was called one mic stand and or
something like that I think it's what's
called one mic stand but it wasn't
called a comicview and keV called me and
asked me if I wanted to do it or if I
would do it and I said yeah but I don't
want to comicview anymore because it's
not common feel it's different they're
flying people out now they're doing it
all right and set it up good and it was
when I signed the contract it's
comicview presents one mic stand they
gave us a big speech before we taped
anything and the guy was like we're
changing comic view it's gonna be
different and the guy specifically said
no more stool humping and
DJ hit it and pulling out fake teeth and
I mean we weren't three comics in before
a guy was wearing fake teeth and fucking
a stool I mean not even a teeth and by
weight when he's giving this speech to
it these same guys who were getting
ready to fuck stools and put in fake
teeth are doing like you know like
staring at him give the speech and like
nodding their heads like like Pacino
speech in any given Sunday like it's
like an emotional powerful speech how
we're changing comic view now and then
they wouldn't put the 18th and they're
like yeah let's go out there and show
the world something and then two minutes
later you're like DJ put that shit back
on you can fuck the bitch with fake
teeth to this one no I couldn't agree
more about DMT and and the the opening
that it can give I mean I had the great
advantage of taking it for the first
time with Terence Mckenna
and he was he said do you want to check
this out okay and that's pretty cool on
the resume by the way first time you did
DMT it was Terence Mckenna yes I won't
say where or when cuz it could be put
down on some record somewhere that's
probably already yes don't worry about
it
but for me it correspondent in many ways
with what people talk about near-death
experiences because i went out through
light into a realm of great bliss and
beauty and then i came back and it was
like coming back from a million miles
away and just coming back into my body
and as it were being born again so it
was it was very much like a death and
rebirth experience for me and and it was
very very transformative incidentally i
think you know what i've been trying to
understand this american phenomena
Southern Baptists and one of the things
that I think is the key to this is that
I think when they talk about being born
again originally baptism was just that I
mean now you can get this through DMT in
five minutes but at the time of John the
Baptist you could get it in five minutes
through being drowned people were lining
up on the bank of the Jordan they go in
he holds them under
if he held them under just long enough
you could actually induce a near-death
experience in a life review at the
drowning man sees his life pass before
him in old Amanda just long enough and
they'd have a near-death experience
almost guaranteed I mean occasionally
they might he might have done it too
long but that was before litigation you
know you might have lost for a
litigation yeah a good theory actually
and then you see they come back they say
I've died
I've seen the light mm-hmm I've been
born again I'm no longer afraid of death
my life has been transformed in five
minutes event and the Baptist's were the
people who revived baptism by total
immersion in the 16th century and
probably now in in America I don't hold
them under that long because this is
post litigation but you know when when
the Baptist's first got going this idea
of holding people under long enough all
their language is the language that
relates to near-death experiences and I
don't think that to start with baptism
by total immersion was just symbolic I
think it was drowning what's needed is
is transparency
what's needed is open do you think the
transparency is gonna be in
eventualities because of the internet
deepening yeah I think it is right
everything gets blown wide open it's
very difficult to keep secrets and it
also it erodes faith in the leadership
when like is this a democracy is this a
representative government or is it some
sort of a weird dictatorship because if
it is a democracy how the fuck are you
keeping that guy locked up how is Julian
Assange still locked up yeah because do
you well I wouldn't I need to know
please tell me what exactly he did that
you need to export him to the United
States
oh he released some information yeah
which is our information we have
citizens that this is not you know
information that should be kept secret
it's not from a king
it's relation it's it's information that
someone who was being paid with taxpayer
dollars did a bunch of shit that the
United States doesn't agree with yeah
everyone was upset by the information
that was released yeah everyone was
upset by that video the Collateral
Murder video everyone was obsessed by
this massive amount of of data that
showed there was a lot
coercion a lot of lies a lot of a lot of
stuff that we don't agree with yeah and
because of that this guy's like public
enemy number one yeah that's that's so
anti what we think of as the United
States completely contrary to everything
the United States stands for yeah
compare and that and so in answer to
your question I would say yes it is some
kind of weird dictatorship yeah
posturing and posing as a as a democracy
because for democracy to be real you
have to have complete openness of
information people must be told the
truth then they can vote and make
decisions on the basis of facts what we
actually have in our society is the
continual very clever massaging and
management of information mm-hmm so it
ceases to be democracy when the voting
when the voting public are fed lies on
the basis of which they they make their
decisions and vote but yeah that isn't
democracy anymore that is and in a way
democracies are the worst kind of
dictatorship because they have this
appearance of freedom you have this
illusion of freedom and everybody can
say well it's great because I live in it
in a democracy at least if you live in a
dictatorship you know you live in a
dictatorship and there are certain
parameters that you have to work your
way around but when you live in a
dictatorship that is posing as a
democracy it's more complicated